if the screenwriters making that switch
from writing for film to then television
does that mean they're gonna be putting
in less hours or more they will be
putting in the greatest hours of their
life there is no more challenging job
than writing for television on staff now
the the fact is that creative writing is
the loneliest job in the world no matter
what medium you are working in it's just
that the pace of television writing is a
hundred times what it is in any other
medium whether it's writing novels film
whatever it might be and so the the
downside of that is that you're you know
the the requirement that you generate
good product in a short period of time
is intense the pressure on these people
is intense but there's some positives
one is you don't have writer's block
right because with those kinds of
deadlines writer's block disappears and
you find all of a sudden when you have
everything you do has an intense
deadline that luxury of writer's block
just disappears you're gonna have to
write something the other great
advantage is that you are writing on
staff and writing snaps are a very
interesting animal especially for the
psychology of the writer because even
though writing is extremely lonely and
the sense of self-criticism is intense
for all writers when you work with the
staff it's all about cracking stories
because we have to come up with a new
story every week and we have to have
that story worked out beat for beat
literally figure out every scene every
story event before it goes to script and
the way it's done is it's done with
everybody's in the room
together cracking stories together and
that's why in in a writers room every
wall is filled with the board's the big
boards and the three by five cards that
lays out every episode of the season and
all of the story events in every episode
and so that requires tremendous
brainpower all working together
and the the great part about it probably
the best part about it is that you were
in effect working in a band you're
playing in a band you and this is these
are some of the best story people
working in the world and when you're in
a room with these kind of people at that
kind of quality it and it's and it's all
working well it's writers heaven because
it you know I equated it's like playing
with the Rolling Stones it's that's how
good these people are they're all great
it's story they're all great it's script
and so you get this cross-pollination of
ideas these these these spitballing
sessions where they break down a story
and it appears before your eyes and it's
just phenomenal just to go through that
process especially if you love story and
you love writing as much as I do but
with every band there's Robert Plant is
the frontman there's John Bonham in the
back desert is there a certain
temperament that's more suited for
someone to be in a group setting like
that because I'm sure that then there
there's a matter of competition or
someone taking a back seat things like
that what's the best temperament for a
group setting like that there is no
preparation for the psychological
difficulty of working in that
environment yes the the the fun of
creating story with these other story
champions is tremendous but the politics
is intense
the competition is intense
sometimes there's backstabbing that goes
on you know I think anybody's worked on
staff will tell you that there is a
tremendous very clear hierarchy that
you're dealing with starting at the top
with the showrunner and how that
showrunner runs the staff makes all the
difference in the world but you have to
be able to attach your ego to the larger
world to the larger goal of making this
show and every episode of the show work
and that means not only being part of
the team
and especially when you're starting out
being at the low part of the team it
also means the requirement to be able to
write other people's characters and not
every writer can do that that is
probably the most difficult part about
it because you have to in you have to
absolutely submerge yourself into that
the shell creators vision and if you
can't do that then you don't want to be
writing for television so maybe go in
knowing that you're going to play a very
very small part even if you're just
worried about working your way up but
even once you reach a mid level that
you're still a very small part in a big
well certainly at the beginning you're a
small part you your part will grow but
your part is really B it's it's
tremendously egalitarian in the sense
that whoever comes up with the best
story idea wins so you can have a
tremendous impact on any show that you
work for as long as you know your story
skills that's why I always tell writers
that's what you're really training for
is become great at story because that's
what that's what they're dying for
that's what they have to generate so
fast but where you have to really mold
your ego is to understand that anything
you create even your own scripts
will be changed
dramatically and oftentimes a script
that you write that has your name on it
when it finally gets to fill it doesn't
have a single word of what you wrote and
if you can't handle that again you don't
want to write for television
so adaptability flexibility absolutely
the number one requirement and if the
television writers that you know how
many hours a day they spend on actually
writing stories essentially 24 hours
they eat sleep talk story and write
story all the time
I remember the we used to have to show
up by 10:00 a.m. they said well that's a
late start except it we the earliest we
got out of that room was midnight and
typically it in two to three o'clock in
the morning and then you go home you get
some sleep just enough time to wake up
and go back in do it for another 12
hours 12 to 14 hours and a lot of times
seven days a week again it depends a lot
on the showrunner certain show runners
they want to make it a livable
experience they don't want it to be hell
to work on the show and so they try to
be very organized and they try to give
you at least one day off a week and so
on
but if the show is not that organized
where the showrunner doesn't work that
way then you're you're in it you know
for 24/7 again the upside is that that
would be the greatest training in
writing that you will ever get and once
you've gone through it you are
completely changed as a writer should
someone realistically say like look I'm
sort of handing over on my personal life
any free time that I'm going to have for
a good year or two and
and just know that this will become my
existence I think it's a very good
approach to it because that was exactly
what happened and it's it's important
going in that you know that that is
gonna happen because the again the
psychological shock is your biggest
problem because there the requirement to
produce quality material that fast is
something you have no matter how much
training you've done in the past no
matter how many screenplays you've
written whether you've written novels
plays and so on it will not prepare you
for what you're about to face and the
psychological hit is the thing you've
got to be worried about
especially right at the beginning it's a
it's like being a rookie and anything
when you first get there first break in
the adaptation that you have to do to
what's going on in that world is on the
writing level is intense but it's also
you have to adjust to the psychology
even the fact that you literally have no
time for personal life and and
especially if you're writing for a
Network show where you have up to 24
episodes per season by the time you're
done with that season that about nine
months you you are this close to being
dead I remember it at the end of the
season on Jump Street the head of the
studio came to the showrunner and said
this was one of Fox's early shows and it
was it was in many ways created Fox it
made Fox happen and so Jump Street with
Johnny Depp was super popular and so the
executive came to the showrunner said we
need two more episodes we'd already done
22 23 24 episodes and the showrunner
said sorry
the horses are dead we can't get
anything more out of them they just
cannot go any farther that was the kind
of intensity that one season produced on
the staff
you